hi
how's it going so
you can probably tell by the title of
this video
what i'm gonna what i'm gonna say
this macbook
16-inch m1
max pro max to the square root of 450 i
don't this is the best decision that
i've ever made i think in my entire life
it's actually probably the best decision
that apple has ever made in their entire
life because this thing is it's beyond
perfect i did a little update showing
you guys before kind of like my desk
tour and not much has changed since then
like this has predominantly been my main
device i don't even turn my mac pro on
anymore i use my mac pro basically as a
stand to put some hard drives on now
this is not to knock that mac pro tower
because that thing obviously has
so many other factors that go into it
like i can plug basically anything into
that thing as far as like power
consumption i don't need a dock i don't
need any types of dongles like it is
just the most perfect beautiful machine
ever but the fact that this little
laptop here completely rivals that
massive tower is just it's just so
mind-blowing and shocking i feel like i
didn't really do a proper follow-up
review to this computer but like this is
it this is the follow-up this is the
best decision that i've ever made so
instead of making like a completely
in-depth full-blown review it's not even
needed this computer is so perfect for
everything that i need it is so powerful
and i'm so glad that i did end up
getting the eight terabyte solid state
drive because i have been so used to
i guess relying so heavily on having
external drives that i kind of forgot
what it was like to basically just take
this with me everything is on everything
that i need i do still always make sure
anything that i have on this i have it
backed up to a separate drive because my
sister back in the day she got her
computer stolen and she didn't have a
bunch of video files on that computer
backed up and that is just kind of like
always in the back of my mind like if
this goes away i still have a backup of
all of what is important on there so
that is a word of advice to anybody just
because you have the space yes you
should use it but you should always have
a backup somewhere else at first i
thought i might have made a mistake that
i should have got the 14 inch but this
16 inch display i am so unapologetic
about it now like i'm on a flight and i
might be sitting super close to somebody
and i have absolutely no room at all am
i sorry that i got the 16 inch nope not
even for a second because this display
is so perfect and i have missed having
that screen real estate for editing like
it is just like a whole new world
especially going for that 13 to 16 it is
just
mind-blowing one of the things that i
love when i'm traveling is sitting in a
hotel room in bed editing do the fans
even turn on no i don't even understand
like how it's possible it is so shocking
it's really just changed the way that i
now work because i would always be so
hesitant to start a project like on my
old 16-inch macbook just because i knew
that if i was editing on my mac pro it
would be so much faster i wouldn't have
to worry about the fan spinning up but
then i was traveling so much that i
really had no other choice and at that
time i didn't know that this was in our
future i've just been so happy with this
and i'm actually really glad that i did
go with a 16-inch but if you do decide
to go the route of the 14 you're also
going to be incredibly happy because
that display is still beautiful and the
fact that it's larger than the 13 inch
m1 pro before you're still going to be
getting more screen real estate but i am
so happy with my choice of getting the
16 inch and it's made me even enjoy
working like i love editing on this
thing everything is just so fast and so
responsive and it just
freaking works and the fact that it is
so silent like the freaking fans never
turn on rarely do they ever i think one
of the things that has really helped me
kind of use this as my
desk laptop is i have one of the owc
thunderbolt docks so i basically just
plop this onto the desk plug that in
plug in my pro display xdrs my speakers
my external drives are all plugged into
the dock and then that's plugged into
this and like i'm set to go so within
like five seconds i go from laptop mode
to full desktop mode and it is just so
amazing if someone's like what else
would you want in this computer maybe
like a usb-a just because i was in
mexico and i didn't have a dongle and i
had a usb flash drive that i needed and
there was no way for me to even use that
because i didn't have a dongle middle of
nowhere there was no stores i could even
get a dongle for so maybe like a usba
just just you know i'm just saying but
that's like the only thing that i can
even think of
i'm speechless this is a perfect
freaking computer i don't know if some
of you guys have had issues with yours
but i've had no problems whatsoever and
it is it's actually shocking to me
because even though i'm such a huge
apple fan there are things that i tend
to sometimes have issues with on some of
my computers nothing like super major
but it's like why is this not working i
don't understand
nothing it's perfect it's beautiful i
love you so
much
say it back
okay it's fine let's find him if you
guys have any questions or comments
about this macbook or really anything in
general feel free to leave them in the
comments below if you want to see the
full review that i did and the unboxing
of this before in case you missed it i
will put it here in the end screen and
in the description so i would love to
see what you guys
think of
that video if you haven't seen it if you
have great lovely you don't have to go
watch it again but um yeah that's it
i'll see you later bye
that was a really poor ending
it's fine it's fine everything's fine